my issue is I'm just talking about the
infrastructure of society so it's like
if we're not doing if we're not making
the most money if we're not doing the
most dangerous jobs how can we say we
have an equal impact as met when it
comes to running Society
there's a problem if men make less money
than women very often it's disappeared
sexual attraction because automatically
we are women not because we want money
money from and of course so it's great I
like to receive help of mine but if men
all time have less money than women she
become to be her son she was your son
and she doesn't respect him we are women
we must respect men who are stronger and
bigger than us otherwise we can very
like him you can almost saw new my cute
boys and we become to be like mother and
son and man inside us he also hate if we
are more stronger